very happy to see that today ministers
agreed they're negotiating position on
the rules we propose to stop the spread
of terrorist content online I also
welcome the progress made today in our
discussions on strengthening the
European borders and Coastguard the
operational measures agreed today to
better fight migrant smuggling are
another example of progress on this
front work must also continue and
accelerate on the revision of the EU
rules are written we cannot live in
Italy Greece Spain or other member
states that may come under pressure the
future to face such challenges alone is
not truly fishtest Osman here in spray
and out of the operative even a Muslim
and arrived after the sad sentence of
agony which eliminates vehicle of
operative total breaking connects and
vital recently her punctum have a
history can see frackie Austin green
shoes own mission focused assassins egg
and the Hin survey Mona Lincoln Scott
said the mix at September colognian is
fight ensues Amin hung with context here
how can he isn't he he any comb so we
had seen timely and assessment items to
someone hung metallic fueling an octave
stand account we hear pizza a notice
internet in this veera kanna Arsenal at
the plant pitch line occur in Snicket if
you notice not Wendy he does we taught
them looking different st. Matthias
online so can often be inserted first
and establish listen in space on dradis
all values needs to last in Hernandez
resources on him in the rare invade he
forgets even Conan Benson to still
Turing and the terroristic eight a
patent offices on enjoy a view to Ella
Islam is your starting state
you